[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn woakes your host and our guest
is David Cameron who is a professor of
political science and the director of
the Yale program in European Union
Studies on jun 23 a small majority of
British voters 52-percent voted in a
referendum to leave the European Union
which many did not think would happen
David Cameron the Prime Minister of the
UK who called the referendum resigned
and Theresa May succeeded him and formed
a new government which is preparing to
negotiate the UK's withdrawal from the
EU today we talk with Professor Cameron
about the referendum also known as
brexit welcome professor thanks Marilyn
it's good to be here thank you so
interesting times let's start with you
know kind of give us a quick overview of
what happened you know with the
referendum that of course everyone is
calling brexit and i have to say
watching jeopardy last night it's one of
those new words brexit is now a new word
that's been created I thought that was
curious so give us an overview well what
happened is that David Cameron the prime
minister called this referendum he
promised back in 2013 when he was prime
minister in a coalition government with
the Liberals and he feared that
conservative voters and conservative MPs
might defect to the UK Independence
Party you kit he said it's time to give
the voters as say have a referendum he
was going to negotiate new terms of
British membership in the EU and put it
to the voters it was an electoral ploy
it worked very well they won a majority
in 2015 but as we've seen now
it was essentially a disaster for David
Cameron he lost he didn't expect to lose
he lost he's now out of not only out of
the leadership in the prime ministerial
position but he's left the house of
commons and now we're facing brexit
right why do you think the Prime
Minister Cameron would have done things
differently if hindsight was 2020
absolutely he thought he would win he
you might say was hubris but I think
also he looked at the electorate and at
the time he looked at the conservative
party in parliament one of the
interesting things about this referendum
is that in the Conservative Party itself
has 330 members of parliament more than
180 came out in favor of referent of
remaining before the referendum so there
was a clear majority in his party and a
even larger majority in the parliament
in favor of staying in right right I
have to say you know I watched that
voting very closely myself because you
know virtually everyone was saying that
it was not going to happen that they
would not vote the UK out of the EU so
it is i think it's mind-boggling that
the people did vote to do so and and
after the election there is talk about
people not understanding what they were
voting for which i find you know
somewhat disconcerting because now
you're in a situation that you probably
don't want to be in I mean is there a
way can they have a vote to vote again
they could if the government was willing
to have a second referendum but Theresa
May has said there won't be a second
referendum the first thing she said when
she became the leader of the
Conservative Party back in july was
brexit means brexit and that's very
straightforward you might say also it's
not only concise but it's circular
nevertheless
durex it means braixen and so from her
point of view and the government's point
of view even though two-thirds of the
members of the cabinet are people who
supported staying in this government is
going to try to exit right right you
know what I was getting at is because if
the people truly didn't understand what
they were voting for does it need to be
looked at again if that's the case well
it probably should be and what's
interesting is that although she has
said no to a second referendum a number
of people have argued that at the least
there ought to be a vote in parliament
before Theresa May acts on the process
starts the process of exiting and that's
now before the courts in in the UK and
ultimately it will go to the Supreme
Court and do you have any idea what way
that will go it's hard to say it's hard
to say the the problem is there is a
there's a process that the EU has for
withdrawal in which member state has to
notify the European Council of its
intention to withdraw she said at the
conservative party conference that the
government would do that no later than
March of 2017 at that point there are
two years the clock starts ticking there
are two years in which to negotiate a
withdrawal agreement if that agreement
takes effect within two years the UK is
out but if there's no agreement and
unless the entire membership of the
European Council agrees to extend the
negotiation the UK is out without a
withdrawal agreement in what would be
called a the hardest possible brexit
meaning no agreement on the relationship
half
the exit okay it seems like it's I mean
this has never happened before with any
other country so it's you know it's it's
a first time occurrence and I would
imagine that there's a lot of questions
that are involved in the process of how
you move forward with this I mean have
you read the documents that actually
explain how this gets taken care of well
what have your complicated do you mean
in the negotiation at this point I mean
for the whole thing I mean well there is
there is a clearly stated process for
for what will happen next at least
procedurally in the treaty of lisbon in
2007 the EU for the first time provided
this process for a withdrawal so we know
what will happen is some time after
march 2017 the EU and the UK will
negotiate and the UK will try to get
what it thinks will be the best possible
deal for itself and the EU will
negotiate with its concerns which
evolved involve among other things
issues such as if we give the UK
continued access to our internal market
for their auto exporters for their
financial services firms will the UK in
exchange accept our rules and
regulations the jurisdiction of the
European Court of Justice will they
continue to apply the principle of free
movement meaning European Union citizens
can continue to move to the UK without
limitations the problem of course is
that there are a number of interests in
the UK that would like to retain the
access to the internal market and the
single market auto manufacturers
Japanese auto manufacturers the City of
London
there's huge money involved in Scotland
there are many interests that want to
stay in the single market but the quid
for the quo is you have to accept free
movement you have to accept regulations
and rules by the EU you have to also
make a contribution to the EU budget and
wouldn't that be just like still being
in the it would be almost that would be
that would be a very soft brexit that
that's more or less what what people are
thinking of when they think of soft
brexit you're out of the EU but you're
in a relationship where you still have
the access to the internal market this
is something that is there Norway
Iceland and Liechtenstein all have this
kind of arrangement the problem is it
means for the British they have to
accept free movement and of course we
know immigration was a huge issue in the
referendum they have to continue to
accept the rules and regulations of the
European institutions and that was a big
issue for many who thought that
Parliament had to regain its sovereignty
they have to accept the court of justice
and they have to pay money so now the
first real thing is this negotiation
between the UK and the EU right that I
think will be very interesting and what
are your thoughts on that well it'll be
very interesting because the the
especially interesting thing in this of
course is that because of the two-year
clock the EU could just sit on its hands
for two years let the clock tick and and
the UK would be faced with an exit in
March 2019 without anything without any
deal at all right oh and what do you
think so they have a lot of leverage the
EU has a lot of leverage in this most of
the discussion right now has been about
what does the UK wat and of course
there's no consensus yet in the
government about what they do want
there's a lot of argument about that
the politicians of the UK pretty much
wanted to stay it's not until they let
it open to the people that it became
this this problem so it's a very
interesting situation I think well it
raises a raises an interesting question
about the role of a referendum because
the question was given to the voters was
do you want to remain or leave and it
was really that simple and there was no
real elaboration of what the
consequences of leave would be and as a
result a lot of voters reacted in a
visceral way and reflecting a
long-standing ambivalence in the UK
about he are they in are they really
part of Europe or not and it was easy to
say leave but the consequences of that
are pretty a quite dire all right I
think also with the people voting it was
really at a time when immigration the
refugee crisis was is was huge and I
think that really played in as well too
in the voters minds I'm sure it did yeah
there there has been an increase of
immigration from EU countries in recent
years since 2012 especially from Central
and Eastern European member states
Poland Romania the largest increases in
the to the UK and so that and that and
in the context of what's been happening
with Syria and the refugee flows into
Europe has really put immigration on the
front burner for the European public as
well as the British public okay so let's
talk a little bit about Theresa May
she's virtually unknown I think in this
country to us you know give us an
overview of her and and how you think
she will broker this deal moving forward
well she's been in parliament since 1997
before that she worked for 20 years in
some of the time for the Bank of England
and in financial services she represents
a constituency to the west of London she
has spent the last six years before
becoming Prime Minister as Home
Secretary which is a very important
powerful position in the cabinet in
charge of policing immigration
ironically immigration home affairs she
was a you might say a quiet supporter of
the remaining she wasn't a outspoken
advocate but she was supporting remain
she's by all accounts a really good
administrator and leader and and will be
an effective Prime Minister for sure and
she's got an interesting government
Boris Johnson is the foreign secretary
who is something of a loose cannon and
there are other important Brett suitors
in the cabinet they've created a new
department in the government called the
department for exiting the EU not a very
not a terrific name for department but
that tells what it's in charge of at
least know what it is and she now has
the job of trying to put together the
position that the UK will want to
advocate in its negotiations and she
will be in charge of that herself there
will be a cabinet committee that she
chairs that will be in charge of the
negotiation on the UK side so I mean
it's sounding like the UK wants a soft
exit would be my guess i would say i
would say there are very strong economic
interest most notably in the city of
london
financial services where they have well
over 300,000 jobs in firms that are
deeply involved in all aspects of
finance in the EU but I think what we're
going to see is some I think what is
taking shape is something that is
neither hardened or soft and she's made
a point of saying we're not doing a hard
exit or a soft exit Allah Norway we're
going to do our own unique deal a
flexible brexit is the way some people
have thought about it where they what
they want to do is is they want free
unimpeded access to the internal market
for certain important sectors finance
auto exporters so forth so they want
essentially all the power rights to
enter the market on the other hand they
also want full control over immigration
they don't want to be under the european
court of justice and the question is can
they get that well can I was going to
say and where is the you the EU coming
down on on their side I mean are they
upset number one that the referendum was
even held I think I think they're upset
about it because it means they've got to
deal with brexit on top of everything
else they're dealing with they're still
dealing with Greece sure I mean you and
I have talked before about grace and the
eurozone crisis that's not over yet they
have the refugee crisis from Syria which
is really the overwhelming issue facing
them just recently they've run into
problems with a very large trade deal
they negotiated with Canada that has now
been put on hold because one region of
Belgium has refused to accept the
agreement so they have their hands
full and they have elections coming up
in France in the spring in germany next
fall where leaders such as Hollande and
miracle or will be contesting so the
last thing the last thing they really
need is is brexit so it's sounding like
it's really in the uk's best interest to
try and negotiate a deal as quickly as
possible with the EU because if that
two-year period runs out they're going
to be in trouble there out there out
without anything and exactly which I
don't think is a place that they the UK
wants to be so do you think that the EU
is going to be i'll use the word
punitive and their approach to their
negotiation I don't think they'll be
punitive but I think they'll be very
tough they're not going to give up on
free movement that is that is a red line
for them and they will not give up on
that and that will be a deal-breaker it
will be unless the British figure an
ingenious way to sort of work around
that and and there was there is some
possibility they could come up with
something that it actually is something
that David Cameron negotiated in
February as his deal that led him to say
okay I've renegotiated I got this now
let's have a referendum they might be
able to finesse that issue the British
might be able to finesse that but the
uke the EU is going to be very tough on
its negotiation because the EU market is
much more important for the UK then the
British market is for EU as a whole and
everyone knows that and the EU also has
very powerful leverage in this not only
the two-year clock that will just start
ticking
but also there are 27 member states so
all of them have to be satisfied in this
deal also the european parliament has to
approve a deal so it's their hands are
going to be tied in so many ways that
ultimately it's going to be the case
that i think the EU will decide what the
deal will be and the UK will have to
accept it right and that's how it's
going to go down and then they will have
to tell their voters in May 2020 that
they got the deal that is in the best
interests of the UK but now then there's
an additional wrinkle in all of this of
course which is Scotland ok because
Scotland has made it very clear that
since they voted overwhelmingly to stay
in that they are going to be very
attentive to whether their interests
will be served in whatever deal the UK
negotiates and if not they will hold
another independence referendum and in
fact put forward a bill an independence
referendum bill last week holding that
in reserve in case they don't get the
deal they want so they will separate
from the UK if what they don't get to
stay and what what the First Minister
Nicola Sturgeon of the Scottish National
Party is saying we are going to try to
get our deal the best deal we can get
for Scotland in in the brexit
negotiation but if we don't get that and
if our interests are challenged and hurt
by the brexit nuh goes agreement then we
will go forward with a referendum
because her view is that it's
democratically unacceptable those are
the words she used for Scotland which
voted sixty-two percent in favor
remaining to have to leave the single
market right even if even if the UK
leaves the EU Scotland wants to retain
membership in the single market and that
means soft brexit so there there are
many powerful voices pulling Theresa May
as much as she may resist it toward a
soft brexit solution and my guess would
be at the end of the day that's probably
what we'll get but no one wants to say
that yet because that antagonizes the
break suitors well I think it'll be very
a very interesting process to watch over
the next several months to see how
things play out several months and years
yes thank you David for being here with
us today and I giving us your update on
brexit for more information about
professor Cameron and his work please
visit our website at MIT macmillan
report yale edu be sure to join us again
for another episode of the macmillan
report made possible through funding
from the Whitney and Betty Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies at Yale
[Music]
I